hallo herzlich willkommen und hochfeld
samira ich heute wieder mit dabei und
heute geht es um richtig leckeres rezept
und zwar machen wir gefüllte champignons
alles weh getan heute im rat nicht dabei
dafür steht auch von euch darauf dass
wir das zurück mit drin steckt und ich
würde sagen ich zeige euch einfach mal
die zutaten und dann erzähle ich euch
gleich was zum rezept und zwar brauche
ich dafür 400 gramm champignons das sind
jetzt ganz große champignons vor allem
sind es weiße champignons und die kann
man einfach super gefühl
dann brauchen wir hier eine schalotte
oder mit zwiebel zwei kleine kartoffel
die haben jetzt etwa 80 gramm zusammen
ich brauche ein einstieg mozzarella
etwas olivenöl und dann einfach nur noch
gewürze wie basilikum pfeffer chili ist
natürlich immer mit dabei genauso ist
alles könnte auch ein ganz normales als
nehmen aber das habe ich mal geschenkt
bekommt deswegen benutze ich das jetzt
einfach weil es richtig gut aussieht so
samira hat mir jetzt mein kochen aber
geklaut aber ist nicht schlimm
jetzt nehme ich bin einfach mal zuerst
die champignons hatte das spür und da
nehme ich jetzt innen einfach diesen
stecker raus es geht ganz gut einfach
mit der hand könnte aber auch ein messer
dafür benutzen muss man vorsichtig sein
gehen auch ganz vorsichtig
also oder schlecht ganz schwer
jetzt nehme ich mir das olivenöl und
gibt es hier in einer auflaufform ich
mache es einfach in so einer form wie
pinsel dass so ein bisschen damit da
jetzt nichts dran klebt und da setze ich
jetzt die champignons rein tipps und
tricks herein ok nich mehr helfen
an der strom genau mit der öffnung nach
oben natürlich eine fähige
und die stille die schmeißen wir jetzt
nicht weg die brauchen wir nämlich
gleich die benutze ich nämlich gleich
für die füllung
jetzt schaue ich einfach ganz kurz mein
gemüse vielleicht noch einen zähler
holen
jetzt werden die zwiebeln einfach fein
gewürfelt ich mach das ist einfach mit
zu einem würfel alligator aber einfach
nur besser machen und das geht natürlich
auch jetzt gebe ich zuerst die zwiebeln
in die pfanne und zwar gemeinsam mit dem
öl natürlich zuerst an die zwiebeln mit
treiben und die werden erst mal glasig
gedünstet und in der zeit kann ich schon
mal das restliche gemüse fein würfeln
und jetzt gebe ich da einfach das gemüse
mit dazu und lass es so etwa fünf bis
zehn minuten mitbraten den er fünf
minuten denn es geht gleich nochmal in
den open das heißt da werden die
kartoffeln dem auge auf jeden fall war
und während des hier so ein bisschen vor
sich hin brutzeln kann ich auch schon
mal den mozzarella nehmen und ihn auch
klein schneiden und das mache ich auch
in einem alligator einfach halbieren
vorher damit es eben kleine stücke
bekommen setzt sich das tier da drauf
und dann einmal durchschneiden
jetzt muss man das ganze noch salzen und
würzen und ich gibt es jetzt einfach
hier direkt mit dazu lasst uns also ich
finde sowas muss man nicht unbedingt
habe ich geschenkt gekriegt und sich
ganz cool aus
vom geschmack her finde ich ändert das
nicht viel weil man benutzt so viel
bargeld und daher aber umso mit chili
benutzen wir jetzt und jetzt fast
basilikum dackeln da jetzt auch frische
nehmen
aber ich finde es da getrocknet hatte
auch ein richtig tolles aroma und passt
einfach auch so was den mozzarella
findest du bist italiener und jetzt gebe
ich hier einfach schon mal so ungefähr
die hälfte von der mozzarella mit dazu
damit es dann auflösen kann
und dann kann ich auch den herd
ausschalten und kann die champignons
direkt befüllen
jetzt nehme ich einfach einen esslöffel
und nehmen von dieser fülle und gibt es
mit in die champignons rein das ist
übrigens im rezept das habe ich mal von
meiner mama bekommen der das früher
nämlich auch immer gemacht und bei ihr
war auch immer carlotta noch mit dabei
also das ist auch sehr lecker
ja
und jetzt kommt einfach noch der
restliche käse drüber und dann schreibe
ich das ganze bei 200 grad etwa 10 bis
15 in den ofen ist es dann einfach wie
sich die farbe verändert und vor allem
wenn der käse einfach verläuft und ein
bisschen goldbraun wird dann sind die
champignons pad ist und dann gleich
wieder raus
so sehen jetzt die fertigen champignons
aus und hier daheim bricht auch richtig
gut ich muss auch sagen ich mag
champignons sehr gerne und aus dem ofen
sowieso und bei uns gibt's die jetzt
einfach als vorspeise ihr könnt sie aber
auch zum beispiel als beilage machen
oder einfach so als snack für den abend
ganz egal wie sie schmecken auch auf
einem buffet zum beispiel ganz gut aber
auch super kalt essen
also ich seh da gibt's einfach ganz
viele möglichkeiten um die 1 sätzen
wir lassen uns die jetzt schmecken und
das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf
salehs - blog.de da schreibe ich euch
auch noch so ein paar
variationsmöglichkeiten rhein zum
beispiel dass man den mozzarella auch
durch schafskäse austauschen kann und so
weiter und ich freue mich schon aufs
nächste mal wieder und wir sehen das
schon ganz bald
bis dahin tschüss